Congress has passed a two trillion
dollar rescue plan to tackle the
economic pain that coronavirus is
inflicting on the country this means
many of you will get money directly from
the government here's how that will work
most adults will get up to twelve
hundred dollars for every child's 16 or
under you will get another $500 if
you're single have a social security
number and our US resident with an
adjusted gross income of $75,000 or less
you should get the full amount if you're
a married couple with no children
earning a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars or less you'll receive a total
of twenty four hundred dollars if you're
filing as a head of household you can
get the full payment if you're in a
hundred and twelve thousand five hundred
dollars or less for now this is a
one-time payment but depending how long
the coronavirus measures stay in place
there could be more payments on the way
Treasury Secretary Stephen Newton says
people should receive their checks in
about three weeks so it will likely take
longer for Americans get their checks
back in 2008 when Congress also send
money to Americans it took almost two
months for it to arrive now most people
are saying that Americans won't get
their checks until May but when they do
a family of four can expect to receive
about $3,400 under the Senate bill
claudia psalm director of macroeconomic
policy at the blushing and center for
equitable growth says this is an
instance where the money for this relief
fund doesn't have to be taken out from
another reserve or budget the federal
government is one of very few entities
that does not have to balance its budget
right households have to like have
income match outflow businesses do state
and local governments do the federal
government does not in a recession this
is a time to Stella's print money take
on like be in a deficit mode have less
coming in in terms of tax revenues and
more going out in terms of support but
not everyone will be eligible for these
relief payments for every $100 you make
above seventy five thousand dollars your
payment will decrease five dollars going
all the way up to 99 thousand dollars
when it cuts out completely so for
instance a single person with no
children making eighty five thousand
dollars per year
would only get seven
dollars because $500 of the benefit
would be phased out by their higher
income Democrats were supportive of the
cash payments but also wanted to use
money to boost America's unemployment
insurance program the Senate bill also
includes a $600 per week
across-the-board increase on top of what
individual states pay for unemployment
insurance but this increase only lasts
for months Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer said the stimulus bill provides
quote unemployment insurance on steroids
body assam says one foreseeable problem
is there are many people who won't be
able to access the fund because they're
not accounted for by the IRS this is
going to be messy to some extent and but
frankly there there aren't other options
right now and that's sad we should have
other options we can't let the perfect
be the enemy of the good right now we
have to do the best we can and get it
out to as many people but it is
heartbreaking that those individuals who
are going to need at the very most they
aren't going to get it and that's why we
have to do things to bolster the singing
you know people who don't get these
direct payments are much more likely to
get picked up in the safety net programs
than they are in direct payments but
even that is not a guarantee this is
gonna take some work to get money and
support to everyone who needs it well
the method for distributing money is up
for debate one thing is clear
American families need all the help they
can get just last week more than 3
million people filed for unemployment a
new record